you talk about working which that's a  house key and and his contributions to  this movie yeah sure so he did some of  the second unit directing for our  reshoots but also his company because we  were lucky enough to get him and his  company 8711 we've worked with that for  the entirety of the shoot and that's  because I really like the way they did  action I thought that like you know it  felt very practical I snuck creator  Jonathan you say Bo and I really got  along and we really loved like the old  Jackie Chan movies and in the way those  those stunts were done in the way that  you shoot that kind of action which is  what 87 11 is sort of known for as well  and so they've been training our ladies  for mods and you know they didn't most  of their own stunt work and then you  know and then it was like when we when  it came time to actually adding even  more action to the movie and reshoots it  was like it was just amazing to get to  work with chad to